[音楽]
むせ数えてもらっていいですかさっき後ろ見た目じゃなくてますよもうこのあーっ
あーっという理由付けた
心霊スポット好きですか
第一
嫌いですね怖いでしょバッジで怖いですあれなんで強いかといいますと
人数少ないから怖いんですよマロウのねはいなるほどガチであるからご覧ください今回
ですね
100人の方に集まっていただきましたあーー小学校前
ええええええ
で今回の現象はですねちらにガチの心霊スポットの久古へ飛んでるという吸ってる事が
あるんでそこにただ2人で行ったらめっちゃ強い子なんでヤバイ事が起きる気がするん
ですけども
走行プランで100人に行くと絶対強くないんじゃないかと言うだろう
金利スポット100人で言ったら怖くない雪音がやっていきたいとおもいます
スウェッのよろしくじゃんああ
事故から100人で移動すると私何かだと分かりづらいと思うんですよ中に一つ3で a
b c d e f g h i j j グルーバーで作ってすぐ点呼をとりやすい
ようにします会え作っていきますチーム
では100に入るともう点呼で作ってチャット先生よもうしゅるくる本杖
早速100人で心霊スポッと向かっていきまっしょーうは皆さん元気にいきましょう
じゃあすごいを隊列9やるが本当に廃ビル共立ですそう
えっこれ
ブーバーこれぞ
今さん大丈夫ですなぁ
[音楽]
ブーバーミニョイこちらがー
赤い橋です赤い橋ハイグリ立てよ
優れない
今日めっちゃの
怖いですねとってもああああでもここまで示すことではありませんこのトンネルからが
心霊スポットです
ご覧くださいうわぁ
皆様疼痛いたしましたーーー
こちらが心霊スポットを置く米トンネルでございます
邑久郷名トンネルでございますみなさんここから何が起きるかわかりませんので細心の
注意を払って前に進んでくださいではいきましょう
準備はよろしいでしょうか
ていきまーす
こんなに盛り上がる攻める時には本当に
たいというトンネル内に入りました
じゃあやばいマジでざわつきがすごい者コメントに本文
これはっはっはー
みんな大丈夫でさぁ
ただや松井子は1ポイントなんか雰囲気がすごいと思った
はい事故で家トンネルんできるんですけどもさらにここに思い子トンネルがあります
最適で皆さん
置く米飛んでですね3パートに分かれておりまして
ここから第2 part になりますその線でいきましょう
ua
はっはっはっました
まあちっ怖くないんだこれ
穂積灘まあ今左でもうすぐすること見えるんですけども
も実があるんですよ人が入れそうなんじゃこれ
てるやつですね入らないんですけどですねここから
何が出てくるっていう
噂があるらしいですです
も気をつけてお取り下さいませ
実は進みます怖いこと言うちょっと前借にどうぞスピリット r リーダーの船には出
てきちゃう方ですよ
レタス間に冊選んでてきてるだろおっけつッ
1件よ僕2
も交えを得ます
すごいです水がてます
うわぁすげぇ銅屑みたいになってるここで皆さん今左手にまたあるんですけどなんか
すごい多くが動物みたいになってるんでぜひご覧くださいません
ニコラスガイド感すごいんだからです
4鉄列車分裂もつ鍋ています観光スポット
皆様もうという出口入り口でございます
同薬は問題ないですかこれですか
ハイネはこんなはマ流ターンして入り口の方まで戻ろうと思います
ni
[音楽]
多くやばくなかったらや普通は言われ
ですはいに早いですこんなんが
ああああああ nao
皆様お気をつけてお帰りくださいません皆様
税率でございます
皆様でしたーーただバスに戻ればでんが心霊スポットなのでそう
外しっかりと帰りましょうかはいみなさん必要で点呼とりまスッタッフくれちゃいます
黒呪
1各自でお願いします
グループ3時に4個
ゾナー hi 10 p あーね再 up も大丈夫でしょうか
僕も大丈夫でしょうか
ん
されていた
大てます大丈夫かあっけないさんなさいつのグループは黒剣の力なくて
[音楽]
ブーブ白に赤ティンヌージャイロ相撲を取って数えます
voodoo 方はパディ
でもっ
確実だしてたも多くに入るとかです
[音楽]
かんにんだも多いで何かあっ
なんかいっ
1着とかはなかったです日本が気付いてないドラえもんなくなってる
出てきておく解説テルマちゃん所いなかったけどアークが
通させては消していくんじゃんぴこ小川がう
言うよ動画とかマシっても大丈夫ですかね
製品これいつもの人マジでだーですこれバレーだから[ __ ]っ
ジャンルちゃん規範機会も風情なこいつぜって彼はねちょっといいですよはいという
わけですね客人で行ったんですけど
ちっちゃな急須や y がそれ結構普通にいいか付け根たセンってやつ
絶対まずっているようなの中にん
ええええええ
レベルシャーク倍強くなっている
なんていう方で設計ユーザーさん
稲さんさんといったん
やばいなぁ絶対まあフックの必要な花です
posted が入ったり体
何かありそうですよねー
ちょっと分担して探します
me
目覚められる re ん
すごいようん
すぐに居ない知っ
やっと普通に済みいなくなることであるないよおかしいって欄で集団行動できないの
印象は今ドキの錯乱とが戦それにそうなんだろうね
すぐ度くれてるんちゃうんバビねー
水槽味噌が今後向けなわけですね
一応熊で言ったらいると思った
あああああ
はぁっ
うわああああああ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
ああああああ
ame
着任する時にしてましたーーー
earth today
絶対来ず間違いああああ
バックオーライざっ皆さんん
モードねぇスポーツ芸どうぞやすくん
ua 開いてあげすけ100人が無いのドッキリしてありがとうございましたーーー
daredevil です今日せっかく100に集まっているのですね今めるぺでお得
なサスメルペールきゃってを紹介したいと思いますねどんなキャンペーンかといいます
と
1月30日から9月16日の間に友だちからの招待コードを入力して登録をすると招待
した人小題された1秒
方ですね1000円分のポイントを取れずが行える大変お得なキャンペーンになって
おります
そしてもうミリ方もいると思われるんですけどもこの進める米の cm にヒカキン
web の一緒に私はず3冊をも出演しておりますなぜか計算で cm 初共演ですよ
目ですね僕が肇社長と樋垣さんとの状態コード8位金を入力していただけると
招待人数分の貯まったポイントでファンと一緒に大きな企画を
実施するアーチポレンタというものをやっておりますもう qsa なんとズーマー
into 6を目指しておりませんぬー勃起取りで殺さてぃるんで102所すると
すごいなああああああ
これを共にも前方てくる入ります入ります大
[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
アイドルの権益が打ち銭湯行ってきましてホッキの大せいか皆さん帰りましょう
うわーっんですよ空港あったりと言っ
じゃあさっきね進めるぺーでもらった大変ではいん
ローソンで買い物をしていきたいと思いますと実感性だ
やそ
開きましたーーー
ましたーーーみんなも8議員で登録すると1000円分のポイントがもらえますので
まだメルヴェをやったことのない方はメルクあるアプリから登録してみてください
吉川動画の概要欄をご覧ください inf 現世すごいずこれは者9人いたから
確かにね千万選んだから10万円
[音楽]
me
ルー
のからん
[音楽]
ん
ふふっ
[音楽]
はぁ